[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero cuando hablamos de niños
nos vamos a pensar solamente en aquellos
niños por agradecimiento como como un
resfriado una cirugía
algún padecimiento de corta estancia
dentro del hospital
el día de hoy les voy a platicar no
solamente algo que es mi profesión sino
de algo que realmente me apasiona
y poder ver y enseñar a todos esos niños
y los búlgaros
hablar de mí los hospitalizados nos
veremos a pensar solamente en cierto
grupo de niños que transitoriamente
pasan por el hospital
ponemos a pensar
te va a desatar una enfermedad crónico
degenerativa
como lo es el cáncer la diabetes la
insuficiencia renal
no ponemos a pensar qué pasa con esos
niños
qué mal escuela de sus niños dejan de
estudiar
gracias
llegaba a la ciudad en tres hospitales
como soy encargada de esta vinculación
con la escuela donde el niño está
escrito
y traer ese pedacito de su salón de
clases al salón de clases dentro de los
también
d
pero
[Música]
pues no tienen más nada
desde las box
están haciendo fila en el baño para
bañarse
y temperamento poder por edades
llegaste
por su padecimiento no los dejé atrás
a la verita a decirme por favor del niño
le hablan
el salón de clases para mí es un área de
aprendizaje dijo
y de diversión
[Música]
de poder regalar recuperación
permitiendo a todos estos niños y puedan
explicar y atender las necesidades
sin habla es una educación digna y de
calidad
donde yo realizo planeación
an dario programas de educación
realizó una ablación anal o funcional
de acuerdo a cada bloque que nos va
marcando el programa para poderle a
pegar a la exploración
de los docentes de los preescolares
maría
fuera del hospital
y el niño
siento como si no hubiera aprendido
ningún momento
es este enlace con sus alumnos con
nuevos compañeros enlace para que ellos
en su salón de clases le den ánimos al
estar dentro del hospital porque es
vital y está comprobado científicamente
que un 80% de la curación del paciente
hospitalizado
[Música]
y un 20
a menos
es esencial que todos de boca en boca
podamos ir sensibilizando a la sociedad
para poder abrazar
d
dentro de nuestro salón de clases
aplicamos todas las asignaturas
pero es que he podido estar aquí
de manera que ellos no sientan que están
estudiando de manera
a veces
y al mismo tiempo está aprendiendo
es también muy padre poder ver como los
jóvenes
d
niños en preescolar pues mi aura es
multinivel e integrada es decir a pedir
los niños de diferentes edades en un
mismo tiempo
y los huesos
o bien dependiendo de la cantidad de
niños podemos estar todos en un mismo
tema
de dificultad
sin su padre ver cómo los niños de
preescolar
el marcador de borradores
a los maestros y enseñarme salud
solamente
como los padres de familia
y les damos talleres en cuadro para
sensibilizarlos y ayudarlos en este
proceso
dios
y yo creo que ninguno de nosotros
en alguna situación
la palabra para nosotros
d
hoy en día una esperanza
la hospitalaria se entable a brindar a
esos niños
una esperanza de
se encarga también de invitar la vida y
la actividad de vida del paciente
hace unos días me habló a uno de mis
primeros alumnos
tuve la oportunidad atrás
hace 8 años
[Música]
y mi corazón el poder
gracias maestro lente y gracias a usted
pude ver más allá del problema en el que
estaba puede ver más allá de mi cama del
hospital de dos sus piquetes y media
tarde comprendí que era para danza
gracias a usted poder cobrar enfocarme
claro que quería estudiar
también la tabla se explicará
nos ayudará a dignificar no les comen de
la calidad de vida del paciente pero la
calidad de la muerte también nos ayuda
la verdad los hospitales
además gracias
[Aplausos]